well it's our pleasure to to be here
this afternoon to talk to you a little
bit about what we've been up to now over
at West Campus my name is Jessica
Coviello I am the director of the Doctor
of Nursing Practice program at Yale
University School of Nursing to give you
a little information about the School of
Nursing we are a part-time three year
program meant for individuals who are
fully employed who are eager for a
part-time program they are all masters
prepared nurses who are looking for a
program in leadership and policy we
began our program only last year we took
in our first class in in 2012 fall of
last year we are a hybrid program we
have four 15-week courses they meet
monthly at the School of Nursing on-site
and in between they have online
assignments which include group work
using Adobe Connect as a means for
meeting they have online assignments
online resources and other than those
particular 15 week courses we also have
intensive x' we have five intensive x'
they occur between terms and we have
three that run in the summer so that is
basically our program we also have what
we consider to be a special group that
offers support to faculty who are not
used to online learning are not used to
hybrid teaching Jeannine batten who is a
medical school a nursing school
librarian myself and Ekaterina Ginsburg
who will be speaking to you in just a
moment Ekaterina is our educational
expert and designer for the online
program and she is very pivotal to our
success at Yale but the three of us act
as a team to mentor folks who are coming
on board to teach in this modality for
the first time
I have to tell you that personally I
very much enjoy the flipped classroom I
enjoy working with folks who've been out
in the field and who are experienced
they bring a richness to the environment
that is terrific the flipped classroom
as you all know is utilized with
assignments that occur outside the
classroom and a lot of hands-on
facilitated work within the classroom
itself I think pretty much most of it
I'm going to hand it over to Ekaterina
who's going to talk to you a little bit
more about our experiences I also want
to let you know that if you'd like to
know a little bit more detail about the
School of Nursing I will leave some
forms here at the desk for you to pick
up that describe the program a little
bit more thoroughly so we we had quite a
journey
picking technology for our online
students hybrid students what have you
you know comfortable calling them we do
have students from all over the United
States and our first cohort also has a
student from overseas in Israel she's
located in Israel and she the first year
I had asked to try and not come in on
campus every month because it was
difficult for her financially and she
has a family too so we tried to find a
way of how to bring her into the class
when our students are actually on site
in our classroom so for that we tried
many things we tried Skype wasn't that
great of an idea because we have a class
that speaks and Skype doesn't pick up
every single person who talks in the
classroom then we tried Adobe which
worked even worse for this particular
instance and again it was because Adobe
is not designed for that kind of setting
and so we finally decided to use Cisco
system so we're using ITV we have a
portable ITV well that begins in the old
campus because we moved now we don't
need a portable one we have one
installed but in the old campus we did
have to use a portable system to bring
her into the class and she was able to
participate and hear everybody because
the mic and everything else was more
sophistic
for her to hear every single person in
classroom we also had a journey with our
LMS learning management system we began
with classes with you and we also used
WordPress that served as a web page for
the course that included schedule I
don't know if I can show it I might
everybody seen classes me too
so it just it just showed us it showed
the students schedule their week by week
syllabus resources that we used from the
library ereserves and it also had about
the course kind of page that's where we
would film our faculty member an
introduction to the course welcoming
students because with we thought this
personal touch would be very helpful for
the students especially they haven't
seen the new professor yet haven't met
them and it had a bunch of hiccups as we
were going through the first year so the
selection of canvas that happened over
the summer was something that we were
waiting impatiently for and when we got
it and looked at it and thought of it
and what we can possibly do now we
decided to switch our second cohort not
the first one because they were way too
much used to classes with you we didn't
want to screw them up so we used canvas
and Jessica's course which is actually
happening right now in the spring
semester is the first course they're
taking through canvas we also was very
important for us to have a portfolio for
the program that students could not only
keep their work but also uses a
reflective piece so the students
actually go through essentials of the
DMP program and they reflect on how they
think they meet them and how the classes
are helping them how professors are
helping them and how they can apply it
for the future so we have a lot and I'm
not gonna go into too much detail if
you're interested you can always contact
us about it so we use canvas for a
portfolio as well and so far it's
working pretty well so this is the first
course as I said and you can see it
right now on the screen so we are taking
baby steps with this LMS just because we
just got
this learning management system we need
to learn before we throw students in and
can't provide support we need to give
students some time to get used to it
especially when they begin with classes
and they got used to a more simplistic
way of delivered information and I don't
know what happened I'm just gonna select
don't update now do that okay so that
that's that's another thing we also in
trying to integrate Adobe Connect with
canvas we're working on this now but for
now students are actually logging
straight into Adobe and they're using it
for group work outside of on conside
classes so when they're on their own
during weekends they're all working
nurses so they have different schedules
sometimes during nights sometimes
because of the time difference they need
to meet at times where we can't really
be there so all of our students have
licenses to be hosts in Adobe Connect so
they're able to create their own rooms
meeting rooms they're able to open them
whenever they want close them record
them whatever they need to do so we
purchased about 35 of those to cover all
of our students plus one GMP faculty at
a time we also have one pro librarian
and one for admissions so that everybody
can create the rooms and and work in the
Dobby Connect so that's something we
also we thought works very well it's a
little bit about its what happens when
you plan for an on-site class and a big
snow class so yeah oh you what we did
last year right so we the students were
scheduled to be on campus for that
particular session and like we said
they're fly from all over the United
States plus I think the student was
supposed to be this one time on on site
a bunch of flights got cancelled but
some of them didn't so we had some
students already flying from California
and as these students were flying from
California and
I was I don't remember which states
exactly the school decides to close and
we have no way of telling them what's
going on and that there is no class
we couldn't report on campus as well but
we knew some of the students who would
be actually in New Haven so not to lose
the momentum plus we knew that these
people took day off from their works to
be in this class so we made a decision
to still go on with the class the class
was supposed to be flipped they were
supposed to read a bunch of information
and then they would have group work on
site with Jessica supervising each group
going from room to room physical room to
room kind of a sign for two and a half
or so hours that was the plan for on
campus and since we had two it was
Thursday night right before we're
supposed to leave we know that we can't
really do that anymore and we were also
not sure if we can get out of our houses
and drive to campus to meet those
students who could make it so we tried
to cancel as many students travel as
possible we still had a couple who flew
in and seven o'clock in the morning well
actually the night before we decided to
prep everything we possibly could and we
did notify them when to log in and where
we created a classroom so we created a
meeting room in Adobe called it
classroom and then we created a bunch of
other rooms so the second slide really
shows the map of where students were
coming from so it's not that important
that we actually see that it's it's
showing where the students were from and
this was the NEEMO blizzard if anybody
remembers when we got snowed in for a
bunch of days and there was no way we
could meet the students even after so
this is the example of what the task was
and I briefly already described it so
what we the solution was to have classes
with you we were still on classes with
you we were not on campus so we still
use classes with you for all the
resources for this particular thing then
we use Adobe Connect and like I said we
did a classroom and then we created a
bunch of group rooms as if - imitates
physical rooms where students would go
and work on their group projects and we
would limit the attendance and that
group only to the group members
then we would have Jessica in her house
with headphones I would be in my house
and we had one person from IT s David
Hirsh he helped us through this who was
also at his house with headphones and
microphone and then warm coffee and see
whoever had the time to grab that and
the most important thing we had good
spirit because very shortly when all
students weren't life we realized that
Jessica didn't have a working microphone
it just stopped working and she was the
one to deliver all the content so we had
a fun way of flipping even more and I
would have Jessica on the phone and she
would speak with my accent to the
students I would basically she would
speak to me and I would speak to the
students right and then and on the other
side I would have David Hirsh trying to
solve that issue so we would have this
thing going and my main main concern was
to mute myself every time I talk to
David and not Jessica and that didn't go
well but we kind of managed the first 10
minutes were good tense but student
didn't really notice it much so as a
result we had about half an hour to 40
minutes of introduction to the project
they were supposed to work on and after
that they split into groups we divided
them I mute I muted all of my groups and
Jessica was clicking on each room in
Adobe walking in and talking to the
students so it was really as if
everybody was on campus they loved it
some of them didn't have to travel they
said some money
they stayed some hassle going through
the snow and getting out of New Haven
because that was also not happening for
a bunch of days and we I think we ended
the class 130 130 so it went a little
longer than it would have in a regular
classroom but nobody seemed to mind
they all got who they all got whatever
they needed to do we gave them some
breaks during this time and ourselves as
well and it went very well
it went and everybody completed what
they needed to do and at the end of that
exercise they all came back to the
classroom again the classroom
and they gave presentations each group
presented on what they were able to do
in those two and a half hours so we
didn't lose any learning time what
opportunity and the class didn't get
backtracked or any of that so it was
pretty good it was everybody was happy
we still remember it's a very good
experience for us and they actually
enjoyed it I mean it was really with a
sense of adventure that you good spirit
and so right after that we developed the
disaster plan and based on that
experience and Sandy because sandy hit a
couple of months earlier we had some
experiences the EMP wasn't likely on a
day they were supposed to be here
something happen and we with the help of
ideas we developed a pretty big detailed
disaster plan for every single thing
that might happen if we don't have an
instructor on campus but we have all
students if we don't have our students
but we have the instructors we have only
partial the students so we have
basically whatever happened to us we
have a solution if something else
happens we will come up with another
solution so if you have any questions
you can always contact us and we'll show
you more any questions